faker the name brings to mind some of
the greatest moments in league of
legends history tries to clean it up for
ryu oh look at the class look at the
moves faker what was that both
incredible highs
and some agonizingly brutal lows lee
sang-hyuk may be esports's biggest star
ever but that doesn't mean you know
everything about him he's a man that
appreciates both clean and filthy eating
he's known for keeping some unusual
company
in my heart somebody help me
it's honestly pretty good he's not
afraid to practice some self-love
i love i love me
and he's got some flashy moves even off
the rift
[Music]
so we're gonna honor the league of
legends goat the only way we know how by
talking about all the weird facts and
strange moments of a long career in the
spotlight and if you think the initial
details on this list are obvious
just wait until things get really weird
please do on the left cheek
i even it out definitely number two
[Music]
all right guys before we submerge
ourselves in faker lore i'm gonna ask
you to like the video subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
because if you don't i think they might
make me live on this sub
and i'm gonna be honest with you
there's no latrine on here all right
guys seal all the hatches pressurize the
hull and let's get strapped in to
explore the faker iceberg level one
early days
alright so faker may not need an
introduction but i do think he needs
some context imagine the year is 2012
you're considering a career in esports
which probably means you live in korea
and you're so good that yeah of course
you're gonna drop out of high school to
play competitive league of legends well
that's exactly what happened to faker
who officially kickstarted his league
career with skt in 2013 but there are a
few things about this period in the
unkillable demon king's career that you
may not know before dropping out to
pursue his esports dream
faker went to mapo high school and it
just so happens that another law legend
was attending the school too deft now
the two weren't classmates and though
deft had heard of faker the two never
really interacted or anything but it's
weird to consider that the two would-be
greats likely fell asleep in some of the
same classrooms even weirder is the fact
that this place doesn't even have them
listed on their alumni page like what
the hell maybe it's because faker didn't
graduate and deaf was only there for a
year
but if it were up to me there'd be a
giant statue of faker outside that
school immediately
a man of many names
you know him as faker but his original
chosen alias was go jon paw which
roughly translates to classic or
classical and honestly that would have
been fitting for his career but he made
the switch to faker because he felt it
just sounded cooler and honestly great
choice the name is so great in fact that
in may 2021 someone managed to get the
summoner name skt t1 faker and tried to
sell it for nearly forty thousand
dollars before riot predictably shut
that down although faker is his main
account he also employs alternate
aliases in solo queue like mid fekar and
most famously hide on bush and whenever
he leaves korea for international
tournaments you can regularly find him
baptizing scrubs on foreign servers
using alter egos
unkillable demon king
we just talked about what faker calls
himself but if you know him you know his
given nickname
the unkillable demon king faker
why is this his moniker well it's
because faker is damned hard to hit with
a skill shot and if you can't hit him
good luck killing him let's see how fake
wait for the animation comes now flashes
wow
beautiful
weirdly in a more recent interview faker
said that he thought the nickname was
childish at first but he eventually came
around to it
record center
as one of the league's most successful
players faker holds a number of records
in the lck not only is he the first
player to play 600 lck games but he's
also the first to reach 1 000 and 2 000
career kills but he's also become famous
for his mastery of certain champions
including his favorite leblanc with whom
he enjoyed a 12-0 competitive streak
back in 2015. faker was so confident in
his ability with the champion that in
the grand finals of msi that year his
opponents edg used it to their advantage
in the fifth and deciding game of their
series fakers leblanc one of the best
yes
he locks it in
for game five
faker
has never lost with leblanc on the
competitive stage unfortunately for
faker he bit off a bit more than he
could chew as edg's comp which was built
specifically to counter his leblanc
ended his unbeaten run on the assassin
in the mid-season invitational here's
the last engage edg doesn't even see the
turrets eyes on skt
sk telecom t1 are wiped the nexus
turrets are going down
lpl's edward gaming are the 2015
mid-season invitational champions
okay that's the obvious stuff out of the
way let's talk pentakills and penny
pinching
how many pentakills
speaking of leblanc faker has only one
career competition pentakill and it just
so happens to be using that champion and
yeah i know what you're thinking only
one pentakill but just watch it and tell
me that this isn't exactly the kind of
penta that you'd expect from him
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
benching saga
as one of the greatest to ever do it you
might be surprised to learn that faker
spent a lot of his time in 2015 in a
position he wasn't used to
on the bench wait what's this
what's this i spy in the skt booth it's
not faker
it's easy hoon long story short league's
mid lane meta that year was shifting
from assassins to control mages and that
favored faker's teammate and mid lane
rival easyhoon who was a master of the
newly introduced champion azir for
someone as competitive as faker playing
second fiddle to easyhoon wasn't going
to fly so after missing out on playing
the 2015 lck spring grand finals he
vowed to work harder to be part of the
team's next big victory and after
spending months grinding away at his
azir and solo queue
baker found himself back in his starting
role for most of skt's games by the end
of the year huge for sk telecom that
it's just easy for them to back off
especially when they're 17. oh fingers
going big flashes and
[Music]
faker with the big play underneath the
inhibitor tower as for easy hoon he
found himself riding the pine all the
way to china in 2016 to enjoy a big fat
payday yeah i'm sure he was really
busted up about that move
friendship with tyler1
faker has plenty to say but he's got a
friend that has him beat in the
verbosity department
tyler1
but i'm picking red he won out here
i feel different but no it's a weird
pairing for sure but one made possible
by the fact that both are members of the
t1 organization are very very korean
chicken i have not that's good is it
yeah maybe we could get some sometime
dude it could be a date
i'm busy sorry and when the two of them
get together it's just a surreal
experience agree to time yeah so i'm as
good as you and you're as good as me
yeah
and in league of legends
this is what i wanted to show you
remember
oh
figures i have
figure 2
hey
let's go
i am big as hell please do on the left
cheek of course i even it out definitely
number two
only one more you ready last one
all right that's a wrap
no
hug it out you just assaulted me not the
first or the last time that someone from
n a had their cheeks clapped in faker's
presence but as we'll see later he likes
his veggies too
no i'm not okay but he got smacked in
the baha'i three times
i'm so sorry that was an experience
but i'm glad i could do it with you
faker
frugal faker as you might expect faker
is loaded but he's not just the highest
paid league of legends athlete in korea
he's the highest paid korean athlete
period and he could have been way richer
apparently having reportedly turned down
a 10 million dollar offer from a chinese
organization so what's he doing with all
this money like where's the t1 clout
house and faker showing off his
collection of sports cars and shoes or
whatever it doesn't exist i've checked
and apparently it's because faker just
doesn't spend that much money like yeah
he bought an apartment for his parents
but also he apparently spends like a
couple hundred a month on himself
[Laughter]
i probably spend at least that much on
just take out in like two weeks listen
when you need it you just need it the
rain whispers faker okay so if you've
been a fan of this channel at all over
the past few years you've of course seen
the faker ryu outplay and yeah reddit i
get it we're not going to stop but i get
it tries to clean it up for ryu oh look
at the class look at the moves faker
what was that this was a critical moment
in faker's career one that proved that
he was clearly aiming for the top of the
korean scene and it was a critical game
in the moment too with a blind pick game
5 enabling the zed vs zed mid lane
matchup but the fallout from the event
might surprise you the event for the lck
summer 2013 finals was actually held
outside on a stage near the olympic
stadium during a seasonal downpour and
let's just say that ryu's teammates on
kt rolster had some trouble forgetting
about well
all of it
but something people have asked is since
both shenz had alt during this duel why
didn't one of them intervene
yeah the game was likely over and alting
would have taken insect away from the
rest of skt but in a now deleted video
insects said that ryu told him not to
alt because he was going to win the duel
i respect the confidence but uh what was
that
yeah enough said let's take a deeper
look at some of his more endearing
qualities
even faker can have a bad day because of
his prowess faker's solo queue exploits
have been covered more than any other
player in fact there was an entire
controversy about this when a twitch
channel that only spectated faker
cropped up during skt's azubu deal but
that means that every little mistake
gets captured and probably none has been
more memeed upon than the time faker
lost a duel to a gold 4 brand player
faker plays a lot of league so the
occasional slip up outside of actual
competition is obviously going to happen
but people just can't let this one go
and it's a perennial post on the league
subreddit as for the brand player
they've been playing a lot of aram guess
this outplay won't lead to the birth of
a new league of legends star
stay healthy we've all had bad hair days
especially over the last year but for
faker a bad hair day led to him eating
broccoli on stage at worlds it's because
that's what a fan said faker's hair
looked like broccoli
kinda random but okay i have to give
some context here faker's holding a
stalk of broccoli and that's because a
fan extended the offer to him and said
your hair looks like broccoli so faker
said all right well if i win i will eat
some broccoli the broccoli was
referenced again in the official rise
music video for worlds 2018
and then again in 2020 for the world
song take over i can't tell you that
eating broccoli will make you better at
league but it is high in fibers so it
might make your losses easier to digest
f is for flash
taking flash is never a question
the only unknown is do you put it on f
or on d it's a debate that has raged
within the league of legends community
for years so it only makes sense that
the game's greatest player ever would
have strong opinions about this
[Music]
teddy
i don't know i just started that way
like season one that's how it started
yeah it's true that more recently faker
has said that it's just a matter of
preference and everybody
foreign
here we are the deepest depths they say
that the weirdest lives deep in the
ocean
faker loves penguins
in december 2019 faker's trip to a zoo
in china got some attention particularly
this picture of him hanging out with
penguins
um
[Music]
he even changed his twitter account's
profile picture to this shot and has
kept it since and it's been over a year
and a half
however when asked by horizon esports if
he'd like to have one move into the t1
facility
he was a bit more reserved
when you're a star your endorsement is
worth money but even though faker
doesn't seem to be hurting for cash he's
definitely appeared in a few strange
commercials whether he's driving a bus
[Music]
cosplaying as ezreal
[Applause]
or doing dorito ninjutsu
[Music]
speed of his hand signs
nobody's that fast
i think the ezreal one is the worst i
mean if baker hand delivered something
to me i'd at least have the courtesy to
invite him in for some broccoli or
something faker's insane camera controls
if you're a high level league player you
watch pro streams or you're an og who
played starcraft then you're probably
aware that there are camera controls
that let you immediately move your
camera to specific parts of the map
using a keybind and faker is notorious
for taking full advantage of this
perspective flipping mechanic
so notorious in fact that several
parodies of his frenetic flipping around
have been made what exactly is he
flipping his camera around to look at
and what is it like to be faker and buy
milk tea
[Music]
faker actually watched the video and
seemed to think it was pretty funny if
that's actually how he buys milk tea i
think i'll just stick to what i normally
do when the employee tells me to enjoy
my drink i'll just make eye contact and
awkwardly respond you too
well we went deeper than the penguins
usually do there was so much to fit into
this video and plenty that we had to cut
so was there anything that you expected
to see in this video that we missed or
anything that particularly surprised you
let me know in the comments below and
until next time
eat your broccoli
josh you need it
in a big way before we fully submerge
our glistening bodies and faker
i don't know why i said it got really
erotic for me all of a sudden we're like
submerging ourselves in it listen
things are heating up down here you know
and uh i i i can't say i'm opposed
disappointed disappointed when you need
it
you just need it
that last one is kind of threatening bro
i was like you need